le taux de maladies psychiatriques et 20
fois plus élevé en prison que dans le
reste de la population
dépression addictions anxiété troubles
psychotiques
un constat qui n'est pas nouveau
pourtant la psychiatrie a dû attendre la
fin des années 80 pour trouver sa place
dans le milieu carcéral
en 1965 le chirurgien de fresnes ne
pouvait que recenser les tentatives de
suicide des détenus
nous en voyons très fréquemment ce sont
les coupures des veines du poignet du
pli du good
en 1976 une longue enquête réalisée par
tf1
s'interroge sur la santé mentale des
détenus l'inter n'en médecine fait alors
un constat qui se répétera disons que
quand même nous avons une
surconsommation médicale qui a tendance
à diminuer au fur et à mesure où il ya
plus de médecins
davantage de médecins pour plus d'
écoute et donc moins de médicaments
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire les
mettre à bas à part les médicaments ils
font pas ils sont un peu limités peuvent
pas grand chose ils voudraient bien
pouvoir supprimer les médicaments par
des des travaux manuels les choses comme
ça mais enfin les gens n'ont pas la
possibilité
treize ans plus tard des services
médicaux psychologiques sont mises en
place dans certaines prisons et les
psychiatres faisait exactement le même
constat que les médecins de 1976 plus il
y a deux moyens médicaux mise à
disposition des prisonniers - il ya deux
médicaments et en 2003 c'est encore le
même refrain voulait donc à rien mais
j'essaie d'en donner le moins possible
ce qui est pas vacillé mais vraiment je
trouve que j'en donne beaucoup trop
un recours massif aux médicaments pour
combler un manque de personnel en
psychiatrie c'est ce que dénonce et en
2003 l'observatoire international des
prisons dans la prison le pica devient
une fois ou deux fois par semaine au
mieux ils voient pas les mêmes personnes
d'ailleurs deux fois dans la semaine et
ce sont des gens qui devraient être vus
de façon très régulière
en théorie les détenus souffrant de
troubles psychiatriques ont taxé à 27
services médicaux psychologiques
régionaux dans les faits une minorité
d'entre eux y ont accès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]